smile
so i'm a big believer in finding your
one word i believe there's one word that
connects
everything in your past and connects who
you are
if you think about the movies you like
to watch the books you like to read the
friends you like to hang out with
you know the jobs you've had the
companies you've worked for there's a
common thread that connects all of them
and for me it's believe and when you
find that one word every decision that
you have to make in your life and in
your business becomes a lot easier
so once i'm here in orlando uh
different background than usual uh
obviously really sick as you can tell
i went to buy uh some breakfast and i
picked up a box of cheerios and what
made me smile when i bought this box
was this so this is the front of the box
and this is the back of the box now how
often have you seen a back of a cheerio
box
so simple and so easy to understand
usually the backs of boxes are filled
with crap tons of crap here it just says
smile this is a great campaign for
cheerios because we understand what
they're about
we know you sell food right like that's
not people don't care what it is that
you sell yet people want to know who it
is
that you are what you stand for and
cheerios stands for smile
so how does that make it easy for
cheerios it's easy for me to talk about
them hey i'm making this video about
them right i'm already spreading the
message i'm smiling
i'm just spreading a smile message it's
easy for their marketing
if they come up with campaigns for what
they share on facebook what they put in
their newsletter
the right stories to tell it should be
all about making people
smile right if they're thinking about
hiring new people on their team they're
thinking about bringing on a new
supplier a new ad agency it should be
somebody who makes them smile
right if you don't like to smile you
shouldn't be a good fit to go work at
cheerios
it's just not the right company for you
to work at and it helps make your
decisions
easier i love this box it makes me smile
i want you to find your word i want you
to find your word and start to really
incorporate into everything that you do
i find some people are really resistant
at the start like i don't know how to
find my word i don't know my word is
or they do find it but i don't know how
to incorporate it i don't know what to
do
uh but a lot of times people just pick
it up and run with it they start seeing
amazing results
when you don't know what your word is or
when you don't live your word
that's the path to unhappiness that's
the path to not achieving success
it doesn't matter what product or
service you sell right service
sorry smile smile is not a product it's
not a service it's a
it's a value right it's something that
that cheerios stands for
they could sell anything right i sell i
believe
right i help entrepreneurs but i could
be doing anything else
so find your one word embrace it
incorporate into everything that you do
and you have a lot more success believe
you guys like this video please give it
a thumbs up below let me know what you
think in the comments
if you think i should do more voices
more videos when i'm sick
leave it below too and click on my face
to subscribe to the channel
thank you so much and i'll see
you